[Music]
strange approach for the eagles head
coach nick ciriani not committing to
anything
starting quarterback uh it's all a
competition and then
you have harry rosem the gm of the team
who will say that they want to go all in
with jalen hurts this year and see what
he can do
i don't know if this is a conscious good
cop bad cop thing but
but but there's definitely a disconnect
in the messages that we're getting from
the eagles chris
yeah it does it seems like front office
and ownership is kind of like hey no
jalen hurts is the guy and i don't know
i
i you get the sense and just even hey
knowing people in the nfl that
you feel like there's a little bit of a
trepidation there
between the coaching staff and saying
like hey we're going
jalen hurts all the way which i i
understand
again like jalen hurts did some good
things there's no doubt about it but i
don't think it's good enough to where
you roll out the red carpet and just go
oh you're the starter
i think that would be the wrong message
to send to your football team
i do he went one and three there was
some good there was some bad
they want to see him kind of still earn
that and earn the respect of the team
and the players
you know i think if you just anoint him
and make him king a little bit i do
think you have some guys in that locker
room go like
what like he just guaranteed starter
like
he wasn't like carving up defenses like
that to where we're just gonna let him
take over the team i think there's
probably a little bit of that
up in the coaching staff to just make
him want to earn that
to to gain everybody's trust within the
organization
the eagles have been in a perpetual
search for a franchise quarterback they
thought they had it in carson wentz and
now they're looking again and
they have jalen hurts the idea i think
is let's see
what we have in him and we'll find out
this year
and after this year we'll make a
decision about next year if hertz
doesn't become
a guy that we think can be the franchise
quarterback but remember
we talked about this earlier in the
program we didn't mention the eagles we
didn't mention any teams but if the
desean watson situation
clears up chris i think the eagles are
going to be one of the teams
at the front of the line trying to get
the guy who's the proven
franchise quarterback there's no more
guesswork if you get to sean watson yeah
i
agree i would expect them to get
involved in that and
they gave us inklings that like jalen
hurts us and slam
dunk the guy we all heard the rumors
about the eagles
they they fancied zach wilson if he was
going to fall so they're
they're obviously had their eye on the
quarterback
situation and they they're not stupid
people there
they realize yeah jalen hurts has some
potential but we can't just like
you know staple him in there as the guy
for 10 years here
no he hasn't he hasn't earned that right
yet either so yeah they're
in in in flux right now
and we'll see where this goes for their
offense in the quarterback
philadelphia miami carolina
maybe even washington plenty of teams
if if this legal cloud can be
cleared away from sean watson i've been
a proponent handle it the right way
don't don't you know and and it sounds
like they're trying to yeah right if
they can do that
there's going to be a lot of teams out
there denver still you think too mike
right you add to that list
i think denver's still in it i think
that well unless they get your guy
unless they get aaron rodgers
potentially
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports